quite a few times when I've been
standing at the bus stop people have
given me money mistaken you thinking but
I was begging rather than just riding on
a bus I was eight months pregnant I was
in the street and somebody stopped me
and pointed out I was pregnant they then
said to me how did you get pregnant so I
did end up saying I had sex with my
husband how do you think I got pregnant
there are so many times when members of
the public come up to me in you don't
they argue look at them don't use I'm
like what is she doing what is she
looking at is it something that I have
to be alert and aware of I feel so bad
sometimes saying please don't do that
but it is really and helpful for many
people disability can seems to be a
complex thing to talk about
perhaps they fear saying the wrong thing
or seeming patronizing mm roads are
uncomfortable when talking to disabled
people according to a survey done by the
disability charity scope a disability
can be a broad range of physical
conditions chronic health problems and
mental health issues some disabilities
are clearly visible while others can't
you see no I don't suffer for my
disability whether I live with or have
cerebral palsy saying a disabled person
surfaced from their disability which was
quite a negative image of a disabled
person rather than someone who just
needs adjustment or the right support to
be able to fly the stole a huge amount
of low-level discrimination but disabled
people face oh they think it's amazing
and wonderful and aren't you incredible
because you're out and about not
something that just should be an
accepted part of society and we're not
all inspirational just because we've got
out of bed in the morning it is actually
one of the most patronizing things for a
disabled person to experience is for
someone non-disabled to come and say
you're so inspirational because if you
say why they often don't have an answer
I'm a disabled person not a person with
a disability person with the disability
is often used by non-disabled people
because they think it sounds nicer but
actually for me
in society that makes my life different
it steps its cobbles its lifts that
don't work my disability is not a
separate part of me that I can choose to
pick up or put down I lost my sight six
years ago one time I was approaching a
curb with Olga she was on the pavement
and I wasn't a gentleman came over and
gave her a stroke it made her stop in
her tracks a bit and I was still in the
road please don't distract her because
she's doing a job she's my eyes I'm not
wheelchair-bound
confined to or in a wheelchair rather I
just use my wheelchair to get around so
I'm a wheelchair user or someone using a
wheelchair the jokes about my speeding
or whether I've got a license are pretty
weird when you consider that my wheels
or Centurion my legs it's not about
avoiding topics they're trying to say
the right thing rather just treating
people as knew yourself we'd wish to be
treated that many things in one society
it's about asking for person's consent
and how they want things to go down
rather than just assuming stop and think
how you talk to anyone else and use that
when you talk to a disabled person just
listen to what they say what would be so
great is if people came up to me and
asked me if they could stroke Olga I
think it's really important to have that
dialogue between me and the person
interacting with me because the audible
world is so important to a blind person
we don't need to be condescended to or
treat it differently
we'd be respected and supported
and if you like movies content to
subscribe